la madre de la activista y disidente
militar argelino mohamed benja lima ha
confirmado que su hijo ha sido condenado
en ausencia a la pena de muerte por un
tribunal militar de argelia lo acusan de
atentar contra la seguridad e integridad
del país y porque españa está
involucrado en esta noticia pues porque
ven halima de 32 años había pedido asilo
en el país donde estaba desde septiembre
de 2019 tras denunciar la corrupción del
ejército argelino sin embargo el
ministerio del interior español se lo
denegó y le expulsó el 24 de marzo de
este año pese a que la pena capital no
se aplica en argelia desde 1993 por una
moratoria benja lima había denunciado su
temor a ser encarcelado y torturado si
volvía a su país
familiares de benja lima y activistas
culpan al gobierno del presidente pedro
sánchez de haber utilizado al joven como
moneda de cambio con argel hay que
recordar que su expulsión se dio justo
después de que argelia rechazara el
cambio de posición de españa con
respecto al sáhara occidental' llamar a
consultas a su embajador en madrid
para con alzar el precio del gas que
exporta a la península ibérica' el
ministerio del interior de españa aún no
se ha pronunciado al respecto pero no es
la primera vez que un ex militar de
argelia es repatriado por españa' y
detenido al pisar suelo argelino en 2021
mohamed abdel a que también denunció
corrupción militar fue condenado a 5
años de prisión por pertenencia a un
grupo terrorista algo que éste niega